Joe Graph, the only the one and
only shirt. Yeah, you got it.
Oh, yeah.
Dude, those are my po. Those are your
boy. Look what he's doing to my boy.
Dude, his things are cute.
Roomies out there, too. Awesome.
There's room.
There's a lot of good people out there.
Zork out there. Brian,
I thought you're going to use it. I am,
but I was going to go in there. What was
that?
Yeah, there it is. Oh, yeah. That made
perfect sense. Of
course. I love that.
Oh.
That transition was sick. Was that?
Yeah.
Got to learn those quick like slide
transitions in and out of pendulums.
It's really
good.
He's got a nice smile.
[Music]
Oh my god, that guy's naked.
I probably can't post this on YouTube.
[Music]
Dude, I'm still putting it on YouTube if
I can. I'm still putting it on there.
All
righty. I see a penis again. If you're
watching this video,
something you may not know is that
there's a naked dude just to the right
of the screen.
He's naked.
Dude, I have to do cameraman
in order to avoid naked, dude.
[Music]
I feel like what the hell? Yes, Joe.
That's great. I've never seen you burn
before.
Joe right now.
What is even happening with those
tangles?
[Music]
Right. But not more than anybody else.
You should do that.
[Music]
You look rugged.
Dude,
with those long tethers,
there's just no way with those tethers.
What? Look at me go.
We use this whole
where
[Music]
Sarah made you forget, right?
Yeah.
I don't want to happen. I was just like,
where is Sarah?
to get something to drink.
Such a beautiful exit. I don't like
soda. He's so familiar with his tangles.
He like knows exactly
what timing it'll come out in
like the quickest and most dense
possible way. Right next to
me. It's good for when you I don't know
if you eat or breathe fire, but they say
oh when you breathe fire. So it is good
to like break up the
I'm putting
my
carbonation. I think
it's break it up into
it guy.
[Music]